WE'LL SEND IT BACK TO YOU.
NEIL: BILL MELUGIN, THANK YOU.
CONGRESSMAN, WE'RE TOLD THAT
THIS ISN'T OVER HERE, AS BILL
WAS TOUCHING ON, THAT THE THEY
DIDN'T HAVE FAR ENOUGH IN THE
INVESTIGATION, REACH FAR ENOUGH
AND SOME INDIVIDUAL MEMBERS
EVEN THOUGH, AS A GROUP THEY'VE
BEEN EXONERATED COULD BE
TARGETED FOR FURTHER
PUNISHMENT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> THIS IS A COLOSSAL REACH
FROM THE GET-GO, I'VE WORKED ON
THE BORDER AND WORKED WITH THE
PEOPLE SIDE BY SIDE EVERY DAY
AND FOLLOWING ORDERS.
THEY WERE PLACED INTO THE
SITUATION BECAUSE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION HAVING AN OPEN
BORDER POLICY.
THEY WEREN'T TRAINED IN CROWD
CONTROL ON HORSEBACK AND THEY
WERE TOLD TO GO THERE.
THEY WERE EXONERATED AND FROM
THE BEGINNING THEY'VE BEEN
CONVICTED BY THE COURT OF
PUBLIC OPINION AND LEADERSHIP
AND HOMELAND SECURITY.
THEY HAD TO DO SOMETHING TO
JUSTIFY THE FACT THAT THEY WERE
FOUND INNOCENT OF THE CHARGES
OF STRAPPING, WHIPPING PEOPLE.
THEY WEREN'T AND NOW THEY'VE
CONCOCTED A 500-PAGE REPORT TO
TRASH THESE PEOPLE AND AT THIS
POINT, I'M NOT SURE ANY BORDER
PATROL AGENT WOULD TRY TO DO
ANYTHING TO STOP THE FLOW AT
THE BORDER, IF THEY DO
SOMETHING LIKE THIS HAPPENS.
A TERRIBLE SITUATION.
NEIL: AND WE'RE SHOWING IT NOW,
IT'S HARDLY BACK TO NORMAL,
WHATEVER NORMAL IS, SUCH
INCIDENTS ARE CONTINUING, NOT
THE HORSE INCIDENTS HERE, BUT,
YOU KNOW, MORE TRYING TO BREAK
THROUGH THAT BORDER.
AND NOW WE'RE TOLD THAT IT'S
POSSIBLE THAT CVB CAN NO
LONGER, YOU KNOW, USE HORSES IN
THE PURSUIT OF MIGRANTS IN AN
AREA WHERE FOUR-WHEEL DRIVE
VEHICLES, EVEN THEY HAVE A
TOUGH TIME THROUGH SOME OF THIS
GEOGRAPHY AND I'M WONDERING,
THEN WHAT?
>> YOU KNOW WHAT, NEIL, IF ALL
THEY'RE DOING IS PEELING BACK
MORE AND MORE THE ABILITY OF
THE CUSTOMS AND BORDER
PROTECTION TO DO THEIR JOB, AND
IT'S DEMORALIING TO THEM AND
MORE DANGEROUS TO THEM.
AND IN THE BRUSH, THAT'S WHERE
THE HORSES CAN GO, AND THEY'RE
SAVING MORE LIVES THAT NO ONE
KNOWS ABOUT IN THE DESERT
BECAUSE THEY'RE ON HORSES.
THIS ADMINISTRATION HAS CREATED
AN EPIC DISASTER AT THE BORDER
AND NOW THEY'RE GOING AFTER
THEIR OWN, WHICH IS TO ME
REPREHENSIBLE LAW ENFORCEMENT
OR LACK THEREOF.
NEIL: WHAT'S WILD ABOUT IT,
REGARDLESS OF YOUR FEW OF THE
SUBJECT, CONGRESSMAN, WE'RE
GOING AFTER THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
TRYING TO PROTECT THE BORDER
THAN WE ARE ADDRESSING THE
HAVOC AT THE BORDER.
IT KIND OF SEEMS BACKWARDS.
>> IT DOES, THEY STARTED THIS
CRISIS WITH THE STROKE OF A PEN
ON JANUARY 20TH OF LAST YEAR
WHEN BIDEN WROTE BACK ON MANY
BALANCES AND SIGNALED THAT THE
BORDER WAS BASICALLY OPEN.
BECAUSE THEY SAID THEY THOUGHT
IT WAS THE TRIANGLE FOLKS AND
THAT'S NOT TRUE.
WE'VE HAD 60 PEOPLE ON THE
TERROR WATCH LIST THAT HAVE
BEEN SEIZED AND MORE HAVE COME
THROUGH, MULTIPLE TIMES.
PEOPLE FROM 160 DIFFERENT
COUNTRIES AND GOTAWAYS ARE DIE
ROCKETIN
ROCKETING--
SKY ROCKETING AND THE NUMBERS
ARE SKYROCKETING, AND GOING
AFTER THEIR OWN.
NEIL: AND REPRESENTATIVE KATKO